one piece in 60 seconds let's go meet
Luffy he's stretchy and he's gonna be
king of the Pirates he starts in a
barrel beats up this lady meets Zorro
meets Nami Sanji beats up this shark
then they all enter the ground light
together the straw hats me the princess
and this reindeer they save this desert
Kingdom and beat up this crocodile and
me drop it they get super high they
collect some seashells then they kill
gods they go back to the ocean their
ship is dying they go to Venice Luffy
Pizza usop Robin gets kidnapped they go
on a train ride and declare war in the
government they get a new ship and a
Frank he's a cyborg and make friends
with Brooke he's a skeleton Luffy
punches the wrong guy the crew gets
owned Luffy's brother is in trouble
Luffy does a prison break and a war he
saves his brother his brother gets
unsafe the crew trains the crew reunites
the crew goes under the sea and to Spain
and to Disney World and to Japan and
recruits Jimmy then they beat up big mom
and kaido and love tail here we come